i wanted to talk to you about the empire
that we meet in this show like we're
used to seeing the empires as menacing
very efficient
like force in the galaxy yet here you
know
with a different tone it could almost be
like a workplace comedy
you know
right
yeah yeah
yeah i mean i think it's just a more
sort of we've been talking a lot about
when you go into like episodic long form
you can't just do baddies and goodies
you know you have to show
all this sort of what i love about it is
there's sort of banal workplace dramas
like i have a whole situation with a guy
in in the empire in the imperials that
is just not doing his job
and so there's like this really [ __ ]
exchange with these two people and then
it just happens to be
you know in star wars yeah but it could
be the office
it seems like both your characters are
just dealing with like bad upper
management
yeah exactly thank you so much
thank you you would do really well if
you came in with us yeah you can be with
us man exactly you get it it's for you
you get it yeah yeah it's not our fault
that people are completely inept
and these two come in and they just want
to clean it up that's right okay that's
right tidy they want to make it clean
and tight yeah with a bit of torture
yeah thrown in always okay well that's
right it is vampire
now i i know that is not the case when
working with diego um can you talk about
what it's like having him be like a
leader there
oh
good
yeah
he sets a good tone but i'm going to go
with you he is a nightmare no he um i
didn't really get to interact very much
uh except just as a person and i i
yeah when number one on the course sheet
is setting a tone like he said you're
sort of in really safe hands you know
he's respectful and kind to people and
really hard working and he's a great
actor so yeah you're sort of winning
when that's your captain he's so
gracious and giving as well and he's
he's just there 100
100 of the time yeah yeah and it is yeah
it's like inspiring to be around him
yeah yeah we are also introduced to a
new droid in this series i've got to ask
you guys you know
given the choice of any droid
in the galaxy that we know from star
wars who would you like to have your
back which droid would you have by your
side oh wow c-3po should i say that you
could say that if you like she learned
about yesterday yeah
r2d2
uh yeah i have a soft spot for r2 but um
k2so is actually a pretty badass
um
pretty sassy you want to deal with that
every day
maybe yeah yeah yeah okay
i'll go with that too then yeah
denise likes them tall and golden
yeah exactly like an oscar i like all my
droids to look like
okay
all right guys it was such a pleasure
chatting with you thank you so much
you